kommen wir nach china von dort erreichen
und seltsame bilder
zwei ärzte sind an corona erkrankt und
angeblich hat sich durch das virus ihrer
hautfarbe verändert ja sehen sie hier
diese bilder vor der korona erkrankung
und dann angeblich mit der erkrankung
das sind bilder aus dem chinesischen
staatsfernsehen von zwei chinesischen
ärzten was ist da los kann das überhaupt
sein dass das etwas mit corona zu tun
hat das wollen wir jetzt wissen von
doktor thomas aßmann er ist sozusagen
unser hausarzt des vertrauens guten
abend herr doktor als man ja das sind
bilder die uns wirklich fragen da stehen
lassen kann das sein dass corona die
hautfarbe verändert manchmal musst du
sagen jetzt vorausgesetzt dass diese
bilder echt sind und kein krieg muss man
sagen nicht das virus hat die haut
verändert sondern die folge des videos
bzw auch die beantworte ich habe mit
diesen artikel durchgelesen der
erschienen ist da wurde beschrieben dass
diese menschen etwa vier bis sieben
wochen auf der intensivstation waren
darunter auch mit einer so genannten eco
behandelt worden sind
das ist eine art künstliche lunge die
außerhalb des körpers dafür sorgt dass
das blut mit sauerstoff versorgt wird
und man muss auch so sagen die autoren
schreiben darin dass es aufgrund dieser
behandlung nach infolge dieser
viruserkrankung auch sonder
leberschädigung gekommen ist und diese
leberschädigung soll diese pigmentierung
gemacht haben also sprich jeder der an
corinna erkrankt und einen sehr
schwerwiegenden verlauf hatte muss damit
rechnen dass sich die hautfarbe
verändert also ich glaube den videos
würdig würde ich sehr viel unterstellen
aber das nicht
da können wir doch alles schon mal
aufatmen vielen dank dass sie mit uns
diese frage geklärt haben